[Music]
[Applause]
i
hello hello hello and welcome back to
the break room it's monday folks we're
so happy to see you here today another
week another break room fight's breaking
out on the segment this is a lip gloss i
know john with
oh so it's my fault yeah yeah john
couldn't resist it
john couldn't resist it uh hey this is
our daily live show that keeps you
updated on all the nerdy news you need
to know live from our very own break
room in somewhere california
wedding we got a we got a lot of good
stuff today guys we have the pictures
you have been waiting for that's right
fresh hot off the presses
photos from glass onions
fresh peppers onion
forever uh uh jamila jamel gets hit
below the belt and we'll tell you where
uh and uh hey angelico i'm glad you're
here because we're actually have some
star trek news today heck yeah i'm so
happy just for you
just for you we manipulated the news
oh um it is good news well i guess it's
good news i don't know if you're like
it's bad news
oh i know what you're gonna yeah we'll
get to that we'll get to that hey it's
monday we are gonna motivate you i'm
brandon but i'm not here alone as i've
been talking to people i hope uh across
the table from me we have angelica trey
say hello
hello hello it's gonna be back thank you
uh and always as always jessica clements
here hi daschle get me on camera four
are you on camera four you're on camera
four daschle dash what camera four
that's right hey trash bags uh-oh
tommy's out but jessica's in and i'll be
as aggressive and mean to you as tommy
is hopefully it comes off
oh yeah it's motivational monday yeah
what's up
honeysuckles
i love you good day
uh
okay and on camera four we got john
costa
good morning
it's after morning it's afternoon
possibly morning for some people it's 11
00 pm right now from us we love all our
fans in singapore and we will only cater
to them and them watching the show at
you know 4 30 in the morning i dig the
results that's good yeah yeah we're here
for you singapore reach out call in if
you're listening uh hey we do have a
motivational monday redemption today and
we're being very nice and we're setting
at 50 so every 50 dollars in super chats
that we raise we'll give you a
motivational speech that'll really just
get your blood flowing get you ready for
the week it'll be completely supportive
unless jessica gets a hold of it she's
replacing tommy today uh uh and
completely motivational so motivational
uh
it's gonna be great i'm online today and
i haven't even drank like an energy
drink no she's
just water ice water i ate two things of
cheese so maybe it's two things i had
two whole things those
two different cheeses yeah it was the
bay belle cheese we have bay belt cheese
in our fridge in the office and me and
john have been devouring now they're
gonna work any rockstar
i thought it was baby belle i think it's
i think it's bay bill
[Laughter]
get in the comments the table's divided
if you work here for a baby bell or bay
bell cullen uh but before we get to that
we gotta get to the headlines hey
look
i always feel like we have to make noise
during the graphics makes me
uncomfortable you're usually back there
can hear them i thought you just had to
sneeze or something okay as i promised
at the top of the show the biggest media
you've been waiting for new images from
glass onion courtesy of entertainment
weekly and folks let me tell you it's
just people talking
look at them the movie movie people in
costumes
talking look at that oh my gosh there's
more thrilling talking
shots looking at it from revelations i
don't know what it takes place in greece
leslie odom has a weird hat oh my gosh
batista's there john really likes this
movie
so that's why john is very excited we'll
cover this movie until i die i'm kind of
annoyed that there's so much glass in
all the images you got to take the glass
off and then you have an onion i know
it's theme and i know the last one had a
bunch of knives i get it i get it but i
don't know now i feel like we're going
into it expecting too much we're going
to be trying to unravel the mystery from
the jump there's layers yeah lights
break them apart but you can see through
the layers i was like i know it's right
yeah yeah yeah pour one out for my voice
track the track had the thick layers
shrek had a thick layer
not
[Applause]
[Applause]
this is problematic uh previous
conversation this will be fresh uh
spencer grammer who voiced this summer
on rick and morty uh she she did an
interview this week and it turns out she
was once asked to leave the show behind
for a role on another series they were
saying like we need you to leave rick
and morty because we need you more on
this other show but she refused to do it
she said quote i had been in a situation
where i had done another show and they
were like sorry you're gonna have to
leave this and i was like go
[ __ ] yourself
i mean that's just what she said uh this
is the only thing i like i don't care if
i make any money on this show uh good
for you uh uh summer sticking around
they are more money
yeah i mean like she stuck through guys
god knows that grammar family could use
a little bit more cash yeah give him
give him she's related to kelsey graham
uh like father like daughter like father
like summer is yup no way you know what
i picked this story i was like grammar
interesting last name google google
google that's
my daughter
that's insane news you weren't expecting
there you go a little nepotism from
hollywood what do you expect uh uh next
headline she-hulk head writer jessica
gao provided some more insight into the
decision to have smart colt smart hulk
take off to sakaar okay she said quote
as far as bruce leaving we're really
just looking for a convenient way to
make sure that everybody knew this is
jen's show it's not going to be about
bruce and we just wanted to make sure
people weren't expecting to see bruce
every single episode hanging out with
her because frankly we can't afford it
which is the real blow
in that news story uh it's too expensive
to have two hulks running around the
whole time do you think we're gonna get
him again
i think you gotta have like a singer at
some point i think and my breakdown i
mentioned that we saw his mom rebecca at
the dinner table i'm like how are you
going to have rebecca and you're not
going to talk about bruce so i think
there's going to be a scene where
they're on the phone or something he got
he got pretty good reception deep into
space so that was that's the car signals
you know they got strong uh antennas
yeah well they'll probably like trade
out cameos you know so we'll see someone
else and then we'll see you come back
around to bruce
i'm trying to remember if we have any
more bruce in trailer footage you know
we're like oh yeah there's still that or
images
there was the weird like which we may
never see yeah the word like
commercial promo thing that where they
look like they were dressed like 80s
lawyers standing like back to back it
was like a weird promo image that came
out remember oh i think we're talking
about the same thing where they're
dressed up and they're on top of the
roof yeah yeah okay because i was just
like yeah we haven't seen that part i
bet that was like a flashback they cut
or like a weird dream sequence because
we still haven't seen the uh the
daredevil flipping on the roof so maybe
maybe it could be the same room
i think i think we'll see a little
stinger with bruce again because threes
like we've kind of had them twice a
little bit more i agree with our trash
bag graveyard depraved gourd he says
tony stark satellite you got to think
after end game or or the beginning of
end game when stark was stranded out
there he was like we got to figure out
how to do we gotta have deep space relay
that's true that's i can't be stuck with
nebula for another minute he had five
years to figure that out also paul says
it's baby bill which means 78 of you are
wrong
baby bell no i'll look it up later i
don't need you guys
news mark ruffalo is confident that
she-hulk speaks well for deadpool 3
coming out as an r-rated uh film okay he
uh they were he was doing this interview
and they were kind of talking about like
you know what do you see as like the
future with uh deadpool because
she-hulk's kind of allowed to be a
little
a little more uh
body i guess you would say
oh yeah yeah
or it might be with a w i could be
i think
all that kind of stuff it's a little
more risque totally she has sex in the
first episode right yeah um when she
goes on no not in the episode but like i
mean they they hint to a lot of dating
right right right like that so so he was
kind of asked about that and like how do
they think this means like deadpool 3
will continue the trend of the deadpools
of being like r-rated and he said quote
i feel confident that between ryan uh
and the director of the film they're
going to do something that's going to be
very satisfying to the deadpool people
and i do feel like she hulk sort of does
say
quote hey we're open enough and we're
free enough and we're interested enough
to really go anywhere people have the
will and the pleasure to go the creators
of the show did say
it's going to be rated r and i see
everyone in the poll is saying it's
going to be rated r here's what i'll say
i feel like disney's kind of pulled one
a pulled a fast one in the past like
kenobi was going to be like a little
harder
back a little bit i don't think so
because those two writers in so many
interviews have been just like overly
like we don't care we are going to take
it wherever we want and i trust that
they are going to be like annoying about
it i want an nc 17 cut we need more we
need more full
i feel like um with the mcu too and the
disney plus series and the movies
they've been moving in a
broader perspective in terms of some
more adult content as well as some more
you know series that are a little bit
more like pg and
innocent yeah i think the 18 episode
daredevil born again show is gonna be
sort of similar where they're like we're
just gonna i mean daredevil itself is
already pretty brutal and it's on disney
plus already so they're leading up to it
with a lot of more kind of risque stuff
well they didn't cut anything out of the
netflix shows right it was confirmed i
didn't really cut anything out i don't
know
jessica jones is uh i don't know about
just i know
well here's the thing i remember a bunch
of news around them uh like a bunch of
adults that have disney plus getting
upset that they have to change the
parental controls so i don't think that
they cut stuff out of it because of that
yeah post post them buying fox they
added that to disney plus right right
right yeah you have like parental
controls and you have to kind of opt in
and out so that makes me assume that
they probably left some stuff i think i
don't think they're willing to
have this battle with deadpool i think
they're not willing to let like deadpool
happen i don't think we're gonna see
like 20 r-rated mcu movies as a result i
think they're just not gonna be the
certain ones and then might kind of
continue what they're doing yeah
a great agreed agreement one thing that
we can't agree on today one thing you
all agree on uh we will not agree on
chase baby bill uh also in the realm of
mark ruffalo and the mcu and she-hulk my
buffalo is like the the best of these
interviews for just being like they're
going to do a great job and i'm so happy
he's like
so i think he loves cashing his checks
because he's like the only one left now
right so he's like i know how to do
these interviews yeah hey like don't put
clint barton down like that please
he'll show back up if they call him but
i i don't know if they're calling it
yeah do you forget about clinton you
know i feel like every week there's a
new quote from mark ruffalo so i don't
know if this is all from one interview
and they're just
he's just doing he's doing a lot of
press he's doing a lot of it
he's just going live somewhere online
just like here's another thing
i think he also has another film or
project coming out right now so they're
also interviewing him for that okay and
then anytime they get him they ask him
like marvel questions okay uh but he was
saying he was asked about like you know
half of the original avengers are like
gone now like you're still around do you
want to keep doing this yeah and what do
you see is like the future of hulk uh
and he said one of the he said a couple
funny things but one of them the things
he said was that him and edward norton
joked that hulk is like our generation's
hamlet we're all going to get a shot at
it he keeps waiting for the next version
of it he says i'll probably do it as
long as they'll have me oh so like he
says he makes the hamlet joke but really
hasn't been that many it's been like
eric banner uh edward norton and uh uh
mark ruffalo yeah in the most in the
last 20 years
yeah lou ferrigno did it many years ago
uh uh but no one else has taken it i
think mark ruffalo keeps thinking he's
gonna get recast and they don't and he's
just willing to like keep showing up i
think in a world where they could just
make new hulks yeah and he's like
pushing for the standalone movie right
world war hulk he wants he wants to do
the world war hall and he even said he's
been like reading he likes reading the
old the comics were whole gets like old
yeah and he joked that like 67 year old
hulk that would be very interesting easy
i would love to see it
yeah yeah and i think in a world where
they've
said multiverses exist you can always
just bring in new characters very easily
totally boom boom boom boom boom 71 said
mark ruffalo is the best hulk that's
recently recently
he's also the best hulk he does a great
yeah he does a great job i think edward
norton would have made another great one
it's just nobody wanted to work with him
on that okay he's going to be in uh the
biggest movie of the year the last onion
the knives out story coming december
ready
i'm not going to watch
beautiful uh our next headline jamila
jamel shared a deleted scene of uh uh
she-hulk punching titania that you saw
on like the first episode but in this
deleted scene she got punched in the
quote vagine
here it is for you now i go in i go in
wait was that even
[Applause]
that jimmy come on that's so funny
she's going um
she said like enough men get kicked in
the balls and things what if we like
switched it up a little bit they did
that take it didn't make the final cut
but she was very proud of it she brought
it all the way to jimmy kimmel
someone do the visual effects for that
shot somewhat i mean edited the people
have been doing the visual effects of
those deleted scenes
i don't feel like it's going to hit as
hard yeah i mean the
scene
yeah well i was thinking that but you
know like the joke is the how bad it
hurts for guys i mean
the jeans are kind of strong i don't
know i don't know it might start
if i got punched in the crotch by
she-hulk it would still hurt my she-hulk
yeah because that's a and that's a big
fist too so it's just like punching you
into the wall i did it yeah i take it
you take it yeah do it it will unbox
this a lot of people pay for it yeah a
lot of people pay a lot of money for
that we always do the super chat we
almost did the super chat redemption as
if we raised a hundred dollars one of us
getting a punch in the machine we didn't
do it we didn't do it we didn't do it
but if we hit 500 today i'll get punched
in the regime oh my gosh i would love to
punch you please no you can't take
another hit the doctor said it could be
your last
next
uh daniel kaluuya acknowledged his
absence from black panther wakanda
forever last week an interview wouldn't
cover this but it was interesting he
said quote it's what's best for the
story what's best for the film i'm
excited for it i'm excited to watch it
so not a lot of information i don't know
if it sounds sad i mean
he said in different interviews too that
he was just like he's busy yeah he's
really busy and he's like my character
doesn't really add to that storyline as
much as what i'm doing over here so i'd
just do this thing and they'll be fine
without me again he was being
interviewed for another project and they
they always do that it was on nope on
nope they were asking him like why
aren't you blackpink then he was like
dude i'm doing this and i have my own
film yeah yeah and he's and he also
wants to move in the direction of
producing and directing now which i'm
like go off have fun you got to think he
talked with the writers and directors
and we're like hey
i have all these other obligations i
would love to do the film but like i
can't sacrifice these things can you
move the movie and they were like you
know honestly like we're really happy
for you go do the things we got enough
stuff to do we'll be fine yeah
oh well great next headline uh we got
our first look at some of the guardians
of the galaxy holiday special looks from
funko pops these are funko pops folks
love a toilet it's a blurry funko pop
photo but this gives you maybe an idea
we have no idea what they're doing with
this project other than it's probably
going to be lighthearted a little
sentimental as is most guardians
projects i'm going to cry all right i'm
ready to cry he's ready if santa does
not die
in this film
they're going to canonize santa they're
going to make him a cannon or her a
cannon character an mcu yeah
like a omega level mutant do you think
santa's like from space
ah that's great i think
santa is like interdimensional is he an
alien or is he a god i think he's an
interdimensional being what we would
consider an alien so a god possibly a
god he's got powers i mean there's the
idea that santa exists in the real world
our world as like a tulpa which is like
a a creature that can be created if
enough people believe in it it becomes
real the psychic energy creates it real
and i would argue that santa is real
millions of kids believe in santa and
those kids wake up with gifts that
wouldn't have been there what about me
doesn't that make sense
and this new star trek movie is going to
be good okay we promised angelica some
star trek news star trek and i'm gonna
give it to her even if ugh i get a
little nauseous talking about star wars
you guys are animals star treks are
great it's just i'm just already bored
i'm sorry what you have a problem
i like star trek
are there rules on the hollow deck like
obviously people are using that for
inappropriate reasons
all the questions are pointed at star
wars and we're not going to start this
we've got questions don't forget yeah
we're just going to we got a rare
opportunity here the holodeck is really
cool vr and it they explain obviously we
know what we know what people do with vr
in real life are they doing that on the
ship um i bet they do yeah yes we got a
yes from dazzle i'm sure there's
starfleet regulations but look at
characters like barclay in the next
generation and he does a lot of [ __ ]
things okay i don't think dazzle's ever
wanted to be on the show more than he
did
here's the star trek news and prepare
yourself
the next star trek movie set in the
kelvin universe has lost its director
he's been beamed off the ship uh matt
jackman as we were reporting last week
is very
rumored to be directing fantastic four
still not confirmed
but he's now dropped out as director of
star trek uh his reasoning was
scheduling issues
scheduling all his trips to the bank to
cash his fantastic fortune angelica i'm
sorry angelico it hurts you got a dream
director in your pocket oh do you want
to see come in
i know i know dasha wants jj abrams back
yeah i mean you can bring back jj i just
it always makes me nervous when they
switch over hands like that it's like
okay so it's not the first pick anymore
assuming that matt was the first pick so
i don't know i'm kind of nervous so i
don't like it i say let a computer
direct it
yeah i get ibm's watson yeah
on this this poor movie has been through
so many directors
it was gonna be noah holly which would
have been a lot of fun then there was
gonna be a quentin tarantino movie maybe
which was going to be maybe and final
film shackman seems like a really good
choice
and now it's gonna go
to me you're gonna be attacked the
directors have backed a lot of pressure
that's a lot of pressure
uh yeah they're free uh we did have some
polls uh do you think this scene was how
jamila injured her butthole as famously
reported last week she did tear her
butthole at some point on the set uh 68
percent said yes
you filthy monster
uh uh i think this this if this was how
she injured herself to show the footage
again must have been traumatic for her
on a national platform so kudos how
brave hashtag brave uh so brave uh we
also asked when do you think we'll get
follow-up from hulk's trip to sakaar uh
52 said after she-hulk so we probably
maybe won't see our
green boy again folks we're so close to
a 50 redemption of our monday
motivationals we've been getting a lot
of great super chats like katut who sent
in a super chat saying my wife sune i
apologize apologize if i said that wrong
uh has been having some tough times at
work and cnn could use some motivation
but we're so close and we will motivate
we'll motivate all you little trash bags
and breakers out there is she watching
uh i hope so okay if so i hope great
we're at least entertaining clip it out
clip that out flip it out thank you
are we ready yeah yeah are we ready yeah
are you ready for my break room
breakdown oh
daschle it looks stupid
gosh well i looked no one gave you
permission
use the name of the segment yeah
i love you dachel i'm joking i love
dashley's my best friend so andrew
garfield spider-man the [ __ ]
second to john always second to john
every best friend of mine is second to
john god um andrew garfield spider-man
may make a return you guys and i saw you
yelling in the chat asking for your
spider-man pulls and dawson if you can
go ahead and just put like the toby
mcguire andrew garfield tom holland
miles morales uh any miles morales
i will love you forever that's the
question which is your favorite
spider-man oh we found that question
that yeah what's your favorite
spider-man so
we covered last week that spider-man no
way home was getting the more fun stuff
version that shows andrew garfield uh
it's 11 minutes long you go back to the
theaters to go pay and see it but
there's a little snippet where andrew
garfield's telling toby mcguire and tom
holland spider-man that this is great we
should do this again to which toby
replies you got it i didn't know there
was a clip and i am so sorry you guys
play the clip
daschle
starve
other nerds like us of this beauty
we should do this again you got it
is that what you said ah it is yeah
it is what i said also the camera's in
front of the tv so i couldn't see when
it was done but um yeah so there i know
that it's a little like a little tease
but there's probably a reason why sony
would have put that clip back in and let
you guys see it and there it is
i think so so
basically if we did want to bring andrew
garfield back in and if we wanted to
kind of tie him into the mcu i i think
we could get him in secret wars do we
need another spidey movie before uh with
sony doing that with andrew garfield
before it even shows up in secret wars
and this is to say also that toby
maguire had that like
rumor cameo and multiverse of madness so
it's not beyond them to think about
putting extra spider-mans in like
another multiversal movie i could see
that yeah i don't know if they could if
sony could make another movie before
secret warriors today i mean you pointed
out like fantastic four is gonna come
out before secret wars yeah they haven't
even
named a director yet but we know they're
doing the pre-biz orchest we know they
got action sequences all sure
on the books already
i i don't know if so i mean sony was
like talking a big game
when there was like oh toby's done maybe
and they gotta re-up and they're like oh
we've re-upped and we're gonna do three
more movies with toby uh and it was kind
of just like weird news that trying to
reassure everybody do you think they're
ready to like get another spider-man
movie out before secret wars okay
they'll like tie into it
you gotta think
sony wants another one of these movies
right a spider-man a spider-man's movie
right get them
what that was the
second or third highest grossing movie
of all time yeah something like that
why wouldn't you want another one of
those
so i guess the the problem is going to
come down to like okay what does marvel
want right uh if you're if you're disney
if you're marvel you're like okay the
spider-man character is really important
to us but only in the character right
everything else is like out of our
control
we don't want to be giving a competitor
you know more fuel for their fire to be
making these you know crave the hunter
movies and these madam web movies and
all this stuff
i think
that
the mcu wants tom holland and
maybe peppering in some of these these
guys for fan service just to get a
little bit more draw to to their movie
but i can't see them
you know i can't see them being like
yeah we'll do like six more spider-man
movies yeah let me probably want tom
holland to just like have his own films
and maybe do some cameos i feel like it
stood out so hard sorry i mean no no no
you're good i feel like it stood out so
hard because it was the first
spider-man's movie too so and it was
like ooh the surprise like is it will
they won't they
that wasn't the right use of that but
you know what i mean maybe they'll kiss
and they'll smooch in the next one um
i'll be into that
okay
um but yeah i i don't know i feel like
that's what made it hit so hard and
that's why it's so high-dosing but yeah
i i agree with you i mainly am like it
feels like it's too too rushed it's too
rushed you gave us the big thing that
was no way home that was super big if i
see andrew garfield another spider-man
within the next two years i won't be as
like ecstatic as i saw him but i think
what i would be ecstatic for and i think
is the opportunity is just bringing in
miles morales yeah and i think that
secret wars would be better if you
brought in see miles morales right
because if you brought in toby and
andrew again we're just like okay it's
another
no way home i just saw this not too long
ago i do love them don't get me wrong
but i love miles and this is the
opportunity to bring him into him see
you as a live action character i think a
lot of people are pointing out madame
webb in the chat and i think that's
important because it's going to kind of
set this like the center of the bicycle
wheel of the spokes of spider people
right right and i could see a situation
where sony's willing to
trade out a spider-man for the rest of
them you know what do you mean give the
mcu one of the actors to play spider-man
and mcu movie andrea toby andrew toby i
don't think they would want to be too
old i'm sorry
he's a generational talented
i know they would maybe take garfield to
use as an older spider-man or they could
they'd be willing to like take tom
holland and be like we're going to keep
him mcu constant we can use them
whatever we want sony you can make
movies with all the other spider people
you can introduce miles morales you can
introduce gwen stacy is like spider girl
or and or whatever you want to do you
could do all that and like marvel will
keep a spiderman like in on their bench
and maybe they can trade them out when
they want to
but that way sony can keep expanding its
own spider universe and keep it separate
from the mcu in like a fun way well and
what we do know right is that like
there's a little bit of conflict between
sony and marvel right
marvel wants tom holland to exist in the
mcu and only in the mcu and sony wants
tom hall and spider-man to be both in
the mcu for like relevant purposes but
also in a different timeline even not
even you know they want to be making
movies that take place in the mcu they
want tomahawk and spiderman in a
different timeline but also doing these
sony movies yeah and him being in both
and marvel's like that's confusing for
people if you have the same actor
playing relatively the same role but the
canon isn't together no one's really
paying attention to that stuff uh
jessica gao just gave an interview uh
today um saying like yes there is a
person at marvel who is like in charge
of keeping track of all of the little
seeds that have been planted right here
and there and i'm like no sorry you
can't do this yes you should do this or
here's who this person you know should
be a correct person yeah it has probably
a team
i wouldn't be surprised if people work
in this building are secretly working
for marvel um
it's one person they just have like five
just folders
from like from the corner
but you know that's why secret wars
makes a ton of sense for for these guys
right secret wars in the comics was
an event and jessica you could probably
speak way way more to this than i can
where like every everybody's supposed to
be in that thing right so like that's
way you know if if if toby and andrew
and tom and sony and marvel all want
this reunion to happen the perfect place
for it is secret wars yeah it's it's uh
secret wars is going to be very tricky
for me because they're also there's the
rumor that we're not even going to get
into the x mental after secret wars so
you won't even see the prominent
characters that were in secret wars even
in secret wars i doubt that but you
think you think they're going to come
sooner i'm sure they've got to come the
x-men not just mutants the x-men like
that's what i meant because i was like
we're not going to see capital
well they've been building up and
they've been hinting to this stuff too a
little bit so maybe you know if they
just
sprinkle in some characters here and
there you go ah i recognize that person
could bring in
x-men from another universe that's true
yeah the thing is it has to hit it and
this isn't true this isn't i'm not uh
the film director at all but it's like
you wanted to hit kind of like in game
did you know like how everyone showed up
and together we were excited about all
of them at once yeah versus like
even like us seeing miles for the first
time in secret wars would shake us to
our core and he would come above a lot
of the people that we've already seen
and we wouldn't get that team up that we
want and so i want and secret wars is
tricky because i'm like if you throw
doctor doom only in secret wars we don't
get a pre to him before secret wars
we're not gonna give it damn well about
she-hulk or hulk or make sure or any of
them i'm gonna be like that's dr doom he
made it like so it's like it the balance
is very tricky with secret wars yeah you
bring up an interesting point about
secret wars in its relationship with
endgame right who are the
tony stark and steve rogers of this
phase right like
obviously doctor strange has sort of
played a mentorship role during this
phase but i don't think we're gonna see
and sorry natasha as well uh i don't
think we're gonna see
you know an emotional moment as sort of
resonating as we got an endgame unless
it's someone like
peter parker or peter parker's i think
you mean like who's gonna lead who's
gonna die
oh yeah you had
this is all happening within three years
but they still have to make this movie
right and it will have we'll have those
emotional hits but there's no way it's
the same it's not the same
in premise unless you come off like the
whole or something if you kill the hulk
you could also kill one of the guardians
yeah yeah but i think if you take out if
you kill like uh tom holland's peter
parker right what if he killed that's
heavy because
from from early mcu right yeah i think
you could kill toby um that would be
kind of great no
you know
you could kill wong i mean why would it
be heavy i would
probably turn off the tv
it would take me a long time to come
back to this job
and if if any of the guardians survive
and wind up showing up in secret wars
like that's interesting too right that
could be an end for them
or
i mean we also know like
pretty much
uh guaranteed vision uh we'll probably
die white vision's gonna probably come
back division yeah
it's just written yeah i mean we gotta
see in a day yeah
the modern iteration of secret wars too
that the result of that was kind of like
getting rid of a lot of multiverses and
kind of
uh
winnowing down what marvel had become at
that point and i think that's what they
want to do with all these movies and tv
shows it's kind of like reset the slate
a little bit a little bit speaking of a
character who's already died but would
also be really impactful is if loki did
something even more sacrificial for this
oh yeah yeah in terms of the multiverse
of his story like that would also be
after that
after the show loki and just like really
falling in love with that character even
more i i think that that would be i was
like i'm not if loki died i wouldn't
care
i the loki series did it i mean
because there's more loki's there's
there's a million locations
i'd rather have sylvia our our new our
new loki because our lookie is dead our
new loki that we're like falling in love
with through the loki series he doesn't
get to interact with thor until like
secret wars
yeah and then they enter and that's the
first time that thor gets to see his
brother again and like that's the end
that'll be a heavy moment and like uh
completely devastating what if we get
the evil well this this is what i don't
like what if we get the evil loki for
secret wars we don't get the one that we
saw on linkedin but again it's playing
too much close to gamora coming back and
being right right right that's the thing
that i'm also like see i need that
balance and i need whoever's right now
i'm out of guardians of the galaxy i
hope she dies
i hope she dies gamora needs to die oh
my god once start the camera
kill nebula hey thank you guys for
donating we're going to get to some of
your super chats here in a minute but
first jessica
you got some motivating to do
[Music]
[Laughter]
no i'll just do camera two it's okay
it's too late um look here you guys
it's monday it's the 29th runs due on
the first and i hate it okay and i know
and i hate to be the one that has to
remind you that ren is also due but let
me tell you i'm behind on all my bills
and i know you're watching me on camera
and you're like jessica you are on the
internet you work for new rock stars you
make money
i don't make that much money
i live in l.a and just like a lot of the
people watching in the internet hey i
think we're both making the same in tax
bracket let me tell you right now
yeah rent's due in three days
but remember that today it's not due go
ahead and buy that double whopper from
burger king because it's the best fast
food joint on the planet what go ahead
rent uh spiderman no way home because
it's not available anywhere unless you
have showtime and then you're gonna
invoice new rock stars once you buy it
for the fifth time you know what go get
that starbucks drink it doesn't cost
that much
what music is
that is this enya you know like yeah
like alex said the bills are inevitable
but we can overcome it and also if we
get together as a group maybe if we just
don't pay our electricity at the same
time we don't have to pay electricity we
shouldn't have to pay for these basic
necessities i didn't ask to live i'd
have to be brought into this world i
shouldn't be paying rent y'all let's
just all not pay rent at the same time
get together on the 1st september 1st
we're not paying rent we got it spend
our money on things that don't matter
capitalism
give me that purse
oh you got 49 seconds yeah you want you
want that uh you want to go to chuck e
cheese you want to go to dave and
busters you want to play a bargain go
ahead and play buy that game on steam
that you've been putting in your account
for so long and never wanted to purchase
it if you want to upgrade your
subscriptions go ahead and do it you
don't need to like watch ads just pay
the extra 50 cents i'll pay for it wait
a minute
this money today will go back into your
guys account we'll make sure
strike and i'll stand in the front for
you guys jessica is my joker 100
i will kill what's his name
are you coming for robert de niro i will
kill robert de niro if you guys want me
too
i feel like i i feel like i'm the
closest comp to robert de niro in this
situation i don't like it
probably
come back tomorrow we're doing a
cook-off
we're making a eggplant lasagna i don't
know i don't want to cook i'm making
garlic roasted she's just making garlic
but i do want to say we keep bringing up
this italian thing because we all shared
our 23andme this morning so that and
we're all italians like italy you know
they get they're getting around i guess
i don't know yeah it's a beautiful
country like so many out there and it's
a beautiful world uh and we want to make
it a better place you know what
we all use credit cards guys
it's effective life i use them you use
them we used it and whether we like them
or not uh it is what it is but
what if there was a credit card that
could that can tackle your negative
impact on our climate just by using it
once a day interesting right
that was a real oh
that was a real vote from john well john
i'd like to tell you about the
aspiration zero credit card uh we all
try to make better decisions every day
to try to help the planet i'm i'm
recycling i don't know if it does
anything i don't know what happens once
they take the stuff away from my house
but i'm trying my best i'm rinsing out
the stuff i'm trying to keep it clean
but is it enough i don't know i'm but an
ant on a a giant mountain of troubles
okay it's taylor swift's fault it's i'm
not going to blame taylor swift
about just fine don't bring swift into
this you're going to make them angry leo
michelle
enough
all right what you can do to help out is
switching to using an aspiration zero
credit card uh it can crush your
negative carbon footprint just by using
it daily aspiration zero is the first
credit card that fights climate change
by planting trees with every swipe with
an
aspiration zero credit card you plant
two trees with every purchase you make
and two trees soak up about the same
amount of carbon dioxide from the air as
the average american puts out every day
and along with the reward of knowing
that you've turned buying some avocado
toast into a way to do your part to save
the planet you get the other kind of
green reward too i don't mean the
avocado i mean cash okay unlimited one
percent cash back on all of your monthly
purchases when you hit carbon zero for
the month thanks to people like you
aspirations made a huge impact they've
already planted 75 million trees
that's a lot of trees folks
make your dollars make a difference
apply for the aspiration zero credit
card today and earn a 300 welcome bonus
after spending three thousand dollars in
the first 90 days okay start paying your
bills again uh yeah now now pay your
bills apply right now at aspiration.com
break room again that's aspiration.com
break room to go carbon neutral
effortless effortlessly and earn a 300
bonus that's aspiration.com
break room the aspiration zero
mastercard is issued by beneficial state
bank pursuant to licensed by mastercard
international incorporated good credit
required terms and conditions apply you
guys put pizza and spaghetti in the chat
for john
girl asked for it
so bad
put pizza in the chat hey get the lean
and talk someone
i did not say the four-leaf clover put
that out
you really you really opened their
mouths jessica t.d jones sending out a
super chat saying boycott bills we are
going to hate the bills i hate the
buffalo
you also jessica you really got him on
that burger king comment they max lee
sending in a super chat just the same no
literally any other fast food burger
it's bay bell and it's burger king and
i'm tired well in the chat fighting me
on both of them it's actually burger
bell um oh no i swear to god left side
of the table is wrong today burger bell
the lovely one is problematic today
delicious this i mentioned baby burger
baby belle burger baby
it's time for mandatory fun
wow
but before we get to mandatory fun
angelica's going to motivate you guys
wait okay how do i motivate against
paying bills
it could be about raising a child it
could be about
no sorrow
eating breakfast it could be about going
to the grocery store i'm sorry what's a
horse and cold nugget
motivate people about it it is the worst
does that mean it's a nugget made out of
a horse ankle
i don't want to motivate you
i'm going to cry oh sloppy joes aren't
good i love sloppy joes yeah lunch you
want to motivate them
oh my gosh school lunches oh
oh don't get me started on those little
cartons of milk oh okay i imagine uh
those poor lactose intolerant children
out there amen that's me they're
struggling but they got strong bones
actually i'm not sure if that's true
that might be okay that's propaganda
presented by the dairy industry oh i'm
messing up this motivation
you gotta bring it up
um
love it school lunches great all for
kids eating food yeah and uh it helping
them learn yeah
the
pyramid the pyramid of nutrition at the
very top it's pizza oh i think they got
rid of it was problematic is it this is
bad information what's at the bot what's
this so nothing now it's not stacked
like that it's stacked so everything
touches the top and the bottom it's more
like a fan that makes no sense the
fan of food
very important make sure to fuel your
soul your your stomach and your mind and
uh motivational
uh
go get your school lunches now go walk
into any school
even if you don't go there and actually
i don't know if i want to go for this
you're gonna do that
so bad chicago
speaking of chicago speaking of pizza
hey
ant-man three's right around the corner
we call it ant-man and the los
quantomania right here
um
and
director of ant-man
quantum mania was recently on comedian
tom sharpling's podcast uh if you're not
familiar with todd sharpling neither was
i he's a good friend
sorry tom sorry tom uh he's a good
friend of peyton reed and uh he has
podcasts and peyton reed has uh had him
do cameos in ant-man and a man of the
wasp i don't know if you know this um
he's been cut out of both of those films
so you wouldn't know uh
but peyton reed was recently on uh
recently on tom's podcast and had this
to say
yeah oh no i was not expecting to do
this in real time but
and this is serious i'm not this is not
a gag okay this is actually serious
right yeah okay so this the scene we
were planning to shoot yeah
which was going to be this is not a
spoiler but it was going to be in san
francisco yeah um
we have had to cut
so
this is serious this is serious but
we were supposed to shoot it and uh
again through editorial and there's some
some budgetary issues with that
particular thing it was a very quick
scene
sure but as you and i discussed it was a
very clear okay this is this is the one
this is we're gonna get you and now um
they're not
but i'm holding but there's still a chat
there's still
there is still um
i probably should not have done this on
the air i'm looking at your face right
now
very sad no one likes to be cut out of a
movie even before you've shot any of
your scenes yeah um but uh with the
recent marvel data breach that uh we uh
took part in here at the rockstars uh
that gave us some cut jokes from
she-hulk and some other things uh we
also got some cut
cameos from past present future
uh and maybe some unannounced marvel
films and uh
uh
we actually have all the characters here
today yeah yeah
[Laughter]
again oh my god he's losing his mind
john tommy would go first
i think you have to go first yeah yeah
hey
how's everybody doing hey
how are we doing okay
i'm pizza papa's little nephew my name
is lasagna lad okay lasagna lad always
gets played came up with that one i can
see immediately
here's the thing you know you don't know
about me i've been cut out of every
marvel film oh you were in amazon i was
in iron man one
i was cut out of that one i was gonna be
the jericho missile i thought you were
about to name every marvel film it was
gonna be a captain america that went to
soldiers
i was gonna be gonna be incredible
i was gonna be in thor
i was gonna be in iron man 2. that came
before the avengers i think yeah i did
okay uh i got cut out oh okay i got cut
out because
my catchphrase was too raunchy but i've
been told i'm gonna be appearing in the
new she-hulk film because that uh that
show excuse me is all about sexual
intercourse oh okay it's not all about
that it's not there's more to it it's
not about there's a little bit more to
it it's a glass onion there's multiple
layers but you can see through them oh
no or i'm supposed to be in there you're
gonna be in glass onions i was glad i
they're there in greece and you know
what's next to greece
italy yeah you know okay
generally the glass onions
can i just question yeah go i feel like
you went off script a lot did you me
right now or i mean for the we're
talking to you
oh yeah i don't have a script in front
of me no no on the no
i don't have a script in front of me
they have me show up they have me say my
lines i do the thing that i do best
which is what is this which is complain
about the lack of lasagna okay
and then i say
lasagna always gets laid and kevin
feige's always there and he says you
can't say that it's not in the script
and i say what's my catchphrase if
there's like a marvel after dark i think
you'd be perfect for it thank you i'm
gonna be in shield
no that's not she's gonna be a cheetah
catch me on episode 4 of she-hulk
lurking behind donnie blaze in the
background of every shot
[Music]
oh
because it'll leak so i will i will
reenact it for you this was a scene that
was cut from the eternals there was a
cameo in the internals okay everyone
knows these turtles they had hours of
footage they cut um this this took place
during the 1840s gold rush okay
no it didn't an old prospector was
attacked by the devious oh no you found
one in a cave
so some of the eternals came and helped
with it and this old prospector had to
go tell his friends back at the saloon
about what happened okay yeah and they
don't believe him because it sounds
crazy right yeah it sounds crazy okay
let me get into this no please oh
we're at tootin you guys wouldn't
believe it i was out there painting for
gold when all of a sudden this slimy
cougar came up out of the water and it
tried to batman well i thought it was a
gunner for sure i nearly [ __ ] my
britches oh but i ain't nowhere from the
sky came a beautiful man a beautiful man
and he shot fire from his eyes oh and
then this lady came out of nowhere and
she was faster than a bullfrog spot and
she knocked that shannon cougar back
into the water and then the next thing i
know i woke up in this beautiful woman
who looked like salma hayek she was
touching my head and made me feel all
better about it i swear it was the
craziest thing i ever didn't see hold on
hold on that doesn't seem that doesn't
seem on the up and up
oh you're back
that's all
i thought we're going to ask him some
questions oh do you want to ask him no
it's okay i can draw the character back
out i am an actor okay uh yeah no i was
just gonna ask like what happened to all
the gold
oh the gold i dropped it
that slam a peacoat pete came through
and took it all
yeah he's the one who wears a pea coat
but only a pee cult he's got no britches
on underneath i've been asking for more
full frontal thong in the mcu well he
has barely any dong but it's fully
frontal i don't care i'm not going after
this oh no i'm not going to happen
if you have any more questions from you
strange people from the future
well from my perspective
yeah
he lost it all the time
um yeah
mine was actually an
ant-man and then a walk okay oh the the
second one yeah okay okay
yeah and um
let me go get them i'll go i'm gonna go
get them all right
oh
you pick one
you got me either one because i'm gonna
always hit it is it two x s tommy or
like two okay whatever like hyphen okay
whatever you needed got it whatever you
i got to stay off i got to stay off the
grid sometimes okay i stay off the grid
you know um that one southern jet and uh
yeah so i was i was actually his brother
sunny birch i believe
your brother on the fence
but
they cut me out um they cut me out
probably because i went off script a lot
i'll be honest i went off script alone
i think i can do better than anything
that they wanted and they said no they
said
tone it down two times in tommy and i
said nope that's not what i do no
technically tommy burch was your was
your born your
that was that was the name they gave me
yeah but not the name i took not the
name you talk gotcha gotcha
and what are you two timing
are you doing
ladies
at the barbershop the barbershop guys
the banks i don't know what that means
you've never two times your baba no
okay well after this we'll i'll give you
a little two times oh okay all right
that's horrifying
i'm glad no one has any more questions
what did you do with it what was your
yeah
yeah this character wouldn't know about
moonlight and i i don't know about him
and i showed up
and they said
tommy we just need you to sit next to
next to your brother and look hard
and i said okay and i i went
oh okay and they said that's it that's
that that's all i did i bet that's all i
have to do
they should have paid me more they said
look hard and you closed your eyes and
then shook your head what's harder than
looking like you sucked a lemon
be honest
who's looking hard he was doing some
other stuff it was oh
wait a minute wait a minute i was not
hard you know let me be here
we got pete
pete
lasagna
we got tommy two times
angelica what weird sexual character
well i thought
prospector was sexual well but then you
had uh picot pete
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
no i'm kidding it's not calzone too okay
all right
um
okay so you know do you remember uh
shang chi i remember the vlogger on that
yeah oh the on the bus yeah the bus
vlogger yeah um so
it was actually rumored that the bus
vlogger had a parent
yeah involved so i'm gonna go i'm gonna
go bring him now oh okay oh this is the
parent where are the bus vlogger yeah
chongchi and the legend of the ten rings
exactly
hi
um so i was supposed to play the bus
vlogger's mom
but um unfortunately because i was a
disappointed parent right i wanted my
boy
my sweet boy his name escapes me right
now
good parent good prank i love him but uh
unfortunately he would not join the
family dentist uh
yeah we we have a long line of dentists
and you would not join
unfortunately
my uh a lot of my lines got cut because
i apparently was over acting or
something so were you chastising your
son on the bus yes yes i was i came onto
the bus and i started pulling his ear
and unfortunately there was like a
little bit you know like to get him off
the bus and unfortunately there was a
little bit of blood or something
yeah i also started yeah i don't know
why they said i was overacting a lot but
i was just kind of like throwing things
and you know it sounds like a lot of
overacting
i think this is good
method yeah that's a method a lot of
people say your son was a hero who you
know got some of this footage out there
and really got people aware of uh the
ten rings that their presence was in san
francisco do you you still don't think
he's got a real profession no no i think
the real hero is in dentistry oh yeah so
i'm a little disappointed again
jessica hates dentists uh i have a
question do you know the number one
cause for disease around the world what
is that i don't know no decay mouth
decay no
divide
so syphilis but okay so my question is
yes
my entire top row teeth are gone oh
they're these are all i wear a top i
know no tommy i wear it oh
jessica i'm getting kids tommy has very
nice too but jessica was very bad teeth
that wasn't great uh what do you suggest
i do that right now i just have a
retainer that i put in with my teeth in
it
your teeth are in the retainer i can pop
them out but i would rather not on
camera
um
so you can get uh fillers but you can
also just gum things you know just
embrace them that's very
uh brave blogger a lot of people in the
chat wondering did you see razor fists
on the bus did you find him sexy at all
with his muscles
that was another thing that uh they had
a problem with and i guess that's why i
got cut out because i kept uh i saw
raise her fist and i i stroked his arms
oh okay that could be problematic and
then i was in one hand pulling my son's
ear oh okay and it was
it was very romantic it was yeah anyways
um they said i was like inappropriate so
oh i'm sorry
i'm sorry to hear that it's okay i got a
touch of biceps
thank you so much for appearing on our
show yes of course thank you it looks
like in the poll all of us would have
been cut yeah no brandon brandon barely
squeaked i got a 50 50. i got a 50 50.
vlogger mom got 62.
um what did i i got here's my question
is it better to get cut or worse to get
cut you don't get paid as much as you
get no i know i'm just saying like in
terms of the chat chat really wanted
certain people to get cut and didn't
want other people to get cut oh i see
what's better what's worse
[Music]
i think each of our people should get a
spin off guys we have one minute
actually i think our clock is behind
we're over
we are we want to get to we want to get
some uh super chats uh here for the
cookies says been a while since i caught
one of these live
what's up trash bags what's up here for
the cookies you didn't bring any they
also said santa's a tv agent oh yeah we
didn't get sandwiches with tv
charlie 836 i asked what are your top
five rated r comic book movies you want
to see
one there's a live show
like rare
there's a sex one by matt fraction it's
a great independent run uh it's not
called it's called
something risque so look at matt
fraction's uh rated r comic books it's a
very good one i'm not going to say it
out loud someone's dropping screws
getting a bike bringing their full-on
bike into the house i will say it's
probably not as scintillating as the
questions uh is trying to elicit but uh
i loved uh dark horse comic banks in the
back in the days they had all the alien
predators they did like a batman versus
alien that would be so fun to see like
an r-rated batman versus the xenomorphs
it would be very cool have a predator
show up in there too why not let's see a
lot of blood a lot of gore a lot of
batman
that's what i want
dig it people know i'm a big uh i'm a
big spider-man carnage guy this is great
this is great
carnage or an r-rated venom yeah okay
sure there's a great run where carnage
like takes over an entire town and
starts like uh control mind controlling
people um great run super gory uh
and that's what i want to see because i
want carnage in the marvel cinematic
universe and i'm sad that uh
what we got was what we got that's
awesome we'd like a little yeah a little
more carnage in my carnage movie uh
do you know any good r-rated comics you
want to see is a movie um or just like
hyper violent i guess that they couldn't
do all of them
i like anything that's hyper violent
especially if it's got any sort of
i don't know
i don't know how to better explain that
one but um especially when it has a lot
of
religious
kind of like
like pressure there's a reason yeah
probably yeah
daredevil born again is a really hard
run and it's very religious
religious i just love the juxtaposition
like anything you know like constantine
all that stuff i just love anything that
goes hard but then it has some of that
influence in there yeah do another
constantine with a little more i want
demons yeah a little more gothic horror
to it yeah charlie i'm sorry i didn't
know charlie said no dirty scenes lmao
and i okay so i changed mine great great
like short run is called lady killer and
it's about a woman that's a spy that
murders people like
and it takes place in like the 50s so
she's like a normal like mom like house
wife but she's like nope i actually kill
people at night
here we go um mike chiro says i would
love to see a closer look at who was in
the sky at the end talking about no way
home we did a whole video about that go
look it up i still can't tell where
those things are uh
elijah bowser says can we do a segment
about character she-hulk was involved
with wouldn't that be fun
bookmark it we'll do it this week filthy
uh
says oh we already read that one but i
got an answer
um ben enoch says i would love to see a
mini series
i can't read i'd love to see a mini
series similar to i am groot that shows
little funny moments between tony and
bruce while building the lab and bar
wouldn't you prefer a little mini series
similar to i am groot that is all about
lasagna
no absolutely i love lasagna you guys
listen
no absolutely yeah what's happening in
that what's lasagna lad's motivation i
guess there's there's a bunch of little
tiny mini episodes and lasagna lad is on
sale
and trying to get laid but everyone's
like you you're a creep get away from me
and then lasagna off himself at the end
is it lettuce a
anyways i think that's enough for a
monday folks uh we thank you all so much
for joining us today we hope you've had
a lot lovely monday if you're still here
hit that like button thank you so much
uh we'll be here every day this week uh
we got a new episode of she-hulk coming
out on wednesday night at midnight
thursday day uh it's a big week uh we
got a big holiday weekend and the
month's about to get crazy with content
and we can't wait to go over with it
with all of you uh
we're still doing our clip of the week
believe it or not uh we haven't aired
them for a couple weeks we owe you guys
a bunch of clips we're going to show
them this week uh but you can go on our
discord submit your favorite clips for
our clip of the week you can send in
some voicemails you can chat you can
have lots of fun uh thank you all for
being with us today we hope you have a
lovely rest of your monday and have a
great week lasagna lab will never get
cancelled